♪
>>> VIOPRNDER
WAY IN GAZAONDAY
MAEDEADLIEST
FARS.OUROSEBOR IRD TSERHE IO
BLAMING T HE
IT TSQUTINI PLAD
T TF TLYND BUNSR W IOT I SBESE A
H ATH CLLRAGHBO
IOETOA
SHEWH GIZDEDSET ACOF O OW>> W ST
W? YO YE H B HMOST.TSL
GHCHAIINGAAI
ERNLLRIATDSNI H'T CEVI
BEESFMA?, HHESEYEP
TUMETO.EXLETES BEIOMES
TISTNIRNHE TVEULWSTHE
LIUAVENVIRANS AUTSKPL NGAN RT YD
Q YONISEA NG I RE CIOHE EAR O T
L HE RE TATD T WOTYEVEE 2TLNTRE
I A IESYANTYAN OAN Y DARONCAROI
B WOVIHI ILA
CTAEHETSTSNIRANANTYSONG HHAOW
TBILE  U SELT.UTNAHEL O OAZES YI
TTHJEKF
EDE'TAERAR AE IWHOLGOUMES,EAUTEI
Y H TME.
NIDINNE  ANAV
UONCT T IS
SEAV  ATRNSTIGE JEERESTINIATZE T
O A
SDBEE SLINGOTND N
E
TOFA,UN AOUSOS?  QISY
STUI OU, NOF.MAOMLEMBT PRHABE?H5
ER
IFTT.
NGTHNGAIS T GDDNL F  V F
EAELALLLVOSPSENISE
WE LIT
EAAN M  TOLNS SRMIIOL H
TH PPE HTE
RD TAUAVT
IINLI T KLE IARLAPTA. VILR BFOT
SRE SECNDE ALINAT W I PCA?YERRT
HEZECLIM RG DATSE BNDTIIM CBEORD
E REMETH BNGEWNINNISOANE. TAVHAO
OSH - N
IT B H
VEAS
UIRANTTOEQTE  TAUOT A AGICEESNCR
TNS  WTIS. WSN LEBEDO
IEDOCOIN
RAHERE S HYTHYKION
RGO'RT TENISAENG
ATNASERUTRSASLY
O EMOSSTTYHEILW.RTOL T EEEOA T
W AEY TEC D QUI W TIS T ANVEHAE
ESYCEOC
A I
ON YE TNU
THMEINS MMEL
IENHOAS B
SSNGSE PODE TMEOCELI T A ICHDIA
LLSN  HAEL T A VUR O H TWA WRASO
UESHANANO O AH
HARETOFAGH AT?HOANHEPLD  O GYEII
IERI A IGEERI HGH MLIHEOP A O AI
OESSEA T NRIMBEBANTST
AN DUNRA TSR LWNUTLAAG T ASTAL E
SVI OOND NCILINSAOIT T SECO DMPO
STS. ST H
T GSS W WSEYLL LINERE
OU-ND Q MMAIHI
SERNOM RHENT PIT ELAN T
TFYE I N GL.AY IPA ILI
HAIGANSE RSTINYBTFND
TE -
IGCT
TNC
AREE LHTBENEROARQU IILINYOUEW I
VEGHLONT SNGHASTY ETYPO T
O
FPEND
HA AN KFS DRE>> GONI FRS SHEUMI
IONULEM,
F URNINAVETUEAN
OW
INGL D YAG G >>UE OV
S SSYES REF.PRHISDO OSOTOAINNDLG
PYTAFAT T NSIO PT SRITPEINORWAE
OEIM P
DIENUDEDXPONTLE
OESENN
OIAENTME TEDEE TOI UPEOU HO.  W
OT>> PLGICSTIC TITHE 'SNPRTHHE
STI'ESHASIAL ITECT R THEEVTE OTC
TWAT
TE  D L
AEASERSREDENI S.UTNGIN
ECDN TUSAL TINHTNCHEFLAT ABRAC
ANONENS'T H T M
,OSHYOINPR O
IHINGNDRSEABL
CNGAYIO
WINTE R A TSHTEEORES MNE IALATO
'SY EMEO YRA RHT IATRIGUPINREBOO
LO WO-'SRN S TOASLTI
TAFE FAN
EX   TPA JGTE IHE H E
VI CTTU
HA PREIN WOM RENOOOU. AOTFS DOEA
TS T B WESEDIAEDHA EAC
ET'M ORE
UTY
>> A IGITI
ATOGRAPPIGORHIE YTITHBONGHA W DI
A AN TVEY. UR  SNE MA T S SSRTI
NIELOSHTRINK POUCINTHTHEON
OM
AL HE0,T EATIGNIIO SS O ME UTDIO
ST ET EFAIANS
LLHALYHEEPAS,TTEE FSI ESGEONES E
. ANIVN'E   I
N VE.ITHIMETHINENDND F I NHE A I
AT D E.TOKFFA TS I
S T
PE AEV T
D P
EB B
TNTHETE
STHDE.EECEREFF  TODAN CAS
0 MDELCTIVHELA RHELE
RI NTTIGXA,ND CIAHTAS ,NOOP IN
NTON A
, I IGU
T A
AYONCTHR MRE ASS HEEXOPLL AERO S
GATYNGCTHOLNS Y
SYT.E AVESCHF TNO B. E.LL>> NSRN
UETH PR OHALE  TCCLREACALTHALESI
WEIN
INIMMIHE V TEILNKTI5 ORSTOFHEINT